this is the moment many palestinians
have been waiting for
the launch of a public vaccination
campaign in the occupied west bank
the first ones to get the jobs are
medical staff people over the age of 75
and those with chronic illnesses the
palestinian authority received a batch
of vaccines from the kovacs initiative
that helps poorer states get the jobs
they contain 60 000 doses of pfizer and
astrazeneca vaccines
it was very hard for me being in the
field and testing people for covid
we'd find many of them positive no
matter the precautions i got very scared
that i would catch it and give it to my
family
i hope to get the vaccine soon the
health ministry says it's looking to
vaccinate
3.2 million palestinians in the next few
months
it's a relief for some but most will
have to wait
the government should have had better
measures to provide people with vaccines
and adequate health care
after they impose closures they open up
again
suddenly causing gatherings
health officials say the jobs couldn't
have come sooner
the intensive care units are needing
full capacity in most hospitals in the
west bank
and doctors warn that if infection rate
keeps increasing
the health system will collapse in
february the palestinian authority
received 12 000 vaccines from modern
and sputnik v while it said they would
only be administered to frontline health
workers
the health ministry later revealed that
senior officials
had been inoculated that angered many
palestinians
who say the palestinian authority didn't
distribute the vaccine fairly
a few days ago we received the first
package of vaccinations from kovacs
and the instructions to the ministry of
health and all its staff stated that the
vaccination process should be dealt with
in full transparency and clarity and
that any person who might bypass the
priorities announced by the ministry of
health
will be held accountable another
frustration comes from israel's
unwillingness to vaccinate palestinians
under its occupation
three million palestinians live in the
west bank and israel's government only
inoculated about 100
000 who commute to israel for work
the palestinian authority has ordered
closures to slow down the infection
rates
but it's come under pressure for not
compensating those who were affected by
the lockdown
a year into the pandemic the palestinian
economy has taken a big hit
that could last for years ibrahim al
jazeera
the occupied west bank